[Música]
Hola Yo soy Natalia Cabrera parada y les
doy la bienvenida aquí América este es
el magazine de France 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy el presidente de Chile
Gabriel borich cumple un año en el poder
y ya ha enfrentado varias dificultades
como el rechazo a su proyecto de reforma
tributaria y el no a la propuesta de la
nueva constitución que lo obligó a sacar
de su gabinete a las figuras más a la
izquierda y Dina boluarte cumplió su
primer trimestre al mando de Perú tres
meses de protestas y de una profunda
crisis política y social generada por la
represión a las mismas manifestaciones y
tensiones con la comunidad internacional
que cuestiona su legitimidad y en medio
de la crisis Venezuela ve una
oportunidad mientras que Europa y los
aliados le cierran la puerta a los
turistas rusos Nicolás Maduro trabaja
para aumentar los vuelos
Moscú Caracas
y vamos de inmediato a Chile para
nuestra historia principal Gabriel
borich cumple un año como presidente y
esta semana tuvo un revés en el congreso
con el rechazo a su proyecto de reforma
tributaria con la que pensaba financiar
sus promesas de campaña como la pensión
garantizada y mejorar el acceso a la
educación gratuita el índice de
aprobación de borich está por debajo del
30% y este rechazo legislativo refleja
lo que ha sido su gobierno una constante
lucha contra la oposición cuando el país
comienza a mostrar señales de
recuperación cuando empezamos a salir
adelante de una crisis larga nuevamente
hay un sector que intenta hacer que las
cosas no cambien dejar las cosas tal
cual Y cómo están pareciera que no
aprendemos de las lecciones del pasado
Y es que a veces parece que el objetivo
de algunos es golpear al gobierno
impedir los cambios y vamos a revisar
estos 365 días de borich en el Palacio
de la moneda con tres de sus objetivos
cumplidos y tres de sus desafíos
empecemos por los logros cumplidos el
principal fue en materia económica Pues
obtuvo un superávit fiscal gracias a la
reactivación del mercado del Cobre y del
litio y a la implementación de ajustes
del gasto público tras la subida del
mismo durante la pandemia del covid 19
así como la inversión extranjera que
llegó a su cifra más alta desde 2015 con
17 mil millones de dólares en medio de
las buenas noticias puede tener por
delante el reto de la inflación otra
promesa que cumplió es el aumento del
salario mínimo con la subida más alta en
casi 30 años hasta alcanzar los 500
dólares y beneficia alrededor de 800.000
personas según bloomberg chile es la
tercera nación de América Latina con el
salario mínimo más alto después de Costa
Rica y Uruguay y su tercer logro es en
el servicio de salud amplió el
porcentaje de chilenos que pueden
obtener gratis atención hasta alcanzar
al 80% de la población e implementó un
convenio para rebajar el precio de los
medicamentos
aún por hacer están las grandes reformas
con miras a obtener igualdad social como
el acceso total a la educación gratuita
programas de vivienda y las polémicas
pensiones para revisar precisamente los
desafíos vamos a Santiago con la
corresponsal de France 24 Patricia Luna
Patricia la saludo cuéntenos por favor
Cuáles son los tres grandes pendientes
de Gabriel borich para el resto de su
mandato
no ha sido para nada un año fácil para
el presidente Gabriel borich a los
errores comunes de un debilitante que
toma por primera vez las instituciones
del poder se han sumado derrotas
importantes como la que se sufrió en las
urnas el pasado 4 de septiembre cuando
una abrumadora mayoría de chilenos
rechazó el texto constitucional
destinado a reemplazar la Carta Magna
heredada de la dictadura de Augusto
pinochet eso lleva un desafío asociado
el del segundo proceso Constituyente
mucho más encauzado a través del
Congreso que ha nombrado un comité de
expertos 12 personas el senado 12
personas la cámara de los diputados y
que por el momento no logra concitar el
interés de la ciudadanía mucho más
desvinculada por lo menos hasta ahora
este segundo proceso Constituyente que
del primero el segundo desafío se
produjo esta misma semana con el rechazo
en el congreso por pocos votos de la
Reforma tributaria una reforma destinada
a grabar más a las mayores riquezas del
país y con eso conseguir financiamiento
para alguno de los proyectos sociales
más significativos como el incremento de
las pensiones una de microondas de más
larga Data de la ciudadanía en el país
junto a eso en un tercer desafío serían
los temas vinculados a la seguridad en
un país que ha visto incrementar sus
tasas de homicidio y también de delitos
violentos y que se han traducido por
ejemplo en tiroteos en centros
comerciales en horas punta o también
esta misma semana por ejemplo en el
aeropuerto en un intento frustrado de
asalto en la zona de descarga que
terminó con dos personas fallecidas
gracias a Patricia Luna desde Santiago
por su reporte y cambiamos de tema y
vamos a Perú para revisar la cifra de la
semana 3 son los meses que cumplen en el
poder Dina boluarte para conmemorarlo
invito al ganador del premio Nobel de
literatura Mario Vargas llosa una
ceremonia en la que le entregó la orden
del sol la distinción más alta del país
el escritor peruano le manifestó su
apoyo a la presidenta Dina boluarte en
medio de la aguda crisis que atraviesa
el país y aseguró que en el Perú no se
ha roto el régimen democrático y suelo
que consideró injerencia de los
presidentes de México Andrés Manuel
López Obrador y de Colombia Gustavo
Petro Quienes se han posicionado a favor
del expresidente Pedro Castillo Castillo
fue destituido por el congreso cuando
intentó disolverlo para evitar que los
legisladores se reunieran a debatir su
eventual destitución en medio de
señalamientos de corrupción en su contra
lo que ha generado una ola de protestas
y de represión que deja al menos 60
muertos
a esos gobernantes hay que recordarles
que el Perú
Donde prevalece la democracia y donde
rechazamos
firmemente su injerencia
que viola las normas internacionales y
los más
elementales principios de La buena
vecindad
y más aniversarios Jorge bergoglio
cumplió diez años como el pontífice de
la Iglesia Católica el Papa Francisco el
primero de latinoamericano una región
que representa el 35% de los católicos a
nivel mundial diez años que empezaron
tras la histórica renuncia del alemán
Benedicto 16 y que han estado marcados
por los escándalos de abuso sexual por
parte de integrantes del clero el
informe es de Max Pérez Gallardo
10 años del humo blanco argentino el 13
de marzo de 2013 después de la
controversial dimisión de Benedicto 16
Jorge Mario bergoglio fue elegido como
santo padre de la Iglesia Católica
Francisco nombre que eligió vergoglio
para su papado es el primer sumo
pontífice latinoamericano y jesuita en
la historia de la institución
hermanos y hermanas los dejo por ahora
pero muchas gracias por su bienvenida
por favor recen por mí
el Papa Francisco ha sido uno de los
jerarcas católicos que más ha salido del
Vaticano ha realizado 40 viajes a 60
países diferentes privilegiando naciones
en situaciones complicadas Palestina
Jordania cuba El Congo y Sudán del sur
han sido algunos territorios visitados
por el santo padre su santidad nombre
con el que reconocen al papa los
feligreses ha sido sumamente vocal con
su deseo de trabajar por la
transformación social del mundo
los bienes están destinados a todos y
aunque uno ostente su propiedad
explícito pesa sobre ellos una hipoteca
social siempre
se supera así el concepto económico de
Justicia
basado en el principio de compraventa
con el concepto de Justicia social
los reportes por violencia sexual contra
Menores en la iglesia católica también
han sido abordados por el argentino
desde escuelas católicas irlandesas
hasta conventos portugueses los
escándalos sexuales de la Iglesia
Católica han indignado al mundo en
Irlanda una investigación reveló que en
el lapso de 1920 a 1990 más de 9000
menores murieron en residencias
administradas por la iglesia católica el
reporte indica que 2000 de ellos
sufrieron abusos sexuales en 2021 una
serie de reportes desvelaron que más de
200.000 niños han sido Víctimas de abuso
sexual por miembros del clero francés en
Lisboa una comisión de investigación
independiente requerida por el Vaticano
señaló que al menos
4.815 menores fueron Víctimas de abuso
sexual por sacerdotes portugueses al
menos 100 de los acusados siguen libres
y en funciones bergoglio ha hecho de la
persecución a los sacerdotes
responsables por abusos sexuales una de
sus principales políticas ha hecho un
sentido
algún sentido llamado a una lucha sin
cuartel contra los abusos a menores
tanto sexuales como en otros ámbitos por
parte de todas las autoridades y
personas Pues estamos ante crímenes
abominables que deben ser borrados de la
faz de la tierra
que van a cancelarte de la facha de la
tierra a sus 86 años el Papa Francisco
se ha ganado el corazón de millones por
su activismo político y lucha por
reformar la iglesia católica
y vamos a Venezuela lejos de la invasión
rusa a Ucrania miles de ciudadanos rusos
hacen turismo en este país suramericano
en momentos en los que parte de Europa y
los aliados occidentales les han
impuesto mayores controles y trabas para
ingresar el gobierno de Nicolás maduro
negocia a aumentar la frecuencia de
vuelos directos entre Rusia y Venezuela
el informe es de nuestra corresponsal en
Caracas Daniela Zambrano
es uno de los 80 rusos que hoy visita el
barrio de San Agustín en el oeste de
Caracas a sus 32 años asegura nunca
imaginó estar en Venezuela las
limitaciones de visados y vuelos para
los rusos por parte de otros países han
convertido esta nación suramericana en
un destino ideal los precios también les
resultan atractivos
todo aquí estaba feo y todo estaba malo
pero a mi llegada acá veo que todo es
muy bonito que la gente es muy hermosa
eso me ha impresionado también
el anfitrión del tour reinaldo Mijares
coreógrafo y bailarín de arte
contemporáneo es el encargado de mostrar
los atractivos culturales de la que era
considerada la tercera Barriada más
peligrosa de la ciudad el último año ha
recibido a más de 4.000 ciudadanos rusos
esto ha sido de un gran impacto
económico positivo para nuestro para
nuestro barrio pues es un espacio el
cumbeture un espacio que genera trabajo
para músicos bailarines cocineros
productores historiadores locales en la
ruta los rusos prueban comidas típicas
como la empanada visitan pequeños bares
y bailan al son de los tambores bajo la
mirada complaciente de los habitantes
del sector
a 700 kilómetros de la capital en el
estado nuevas Esparta otro grupo de
rusos visita la isla de cubagua un
exclusivo destino turístico al que la
mayoría de venezolanos no tiene acceso
en el caso de Caracas se trata de un
turismo bastante controlado los rusos
son traslados en transportes del
Ministerio de turismo cumplen un
itinerario específico siempre
acompañados Por guías y sin posibilidad
de apartarse del grupo me gustaría
también por supuesto no me van a dar el
permiso pero me gustaría seguir paseando
por las calles mientras el mundo le
cierra las puertas a Rusia en condena
por la invasión a Ucrania Venezuela
negocia con Moscú el aumento de cuatro
vuelos semanales una decisión celebrada
por reinaldo y los habitantes de esta
comunidad que han visto en el turismo
ruso un importante fuente de ingresos en
medio de la crisis que atraviesa
Venezuela
me despido con música porque la cantante
colombiana Karol G y su historia y se
convirtió en la primera mujer latina en
ocupar el primer lugar de la lista
billboard con un álbum completamente en
español
Dile a tu nueva bebé
que por hombres no compito el álbum
mañana será bonito logró ubicar 11
canciones en el billboard Hot Hundred
entre ellos la canción tqg a dúo también
con la colombiana Shakira que es
simultáneamente la canción Número Uno de
las canciones latinas en la historia del
listado de billboard que Data de 1958
solo Bad Bunny había ocupado el primer
lugar con un álbum en español gracias
por acompañarme en esta emisión de aquí
América Sigan viendo France 24
[Música]
vida pero si ella supiera que me gusta
todavía
[Música]